bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti anche
solo video sono parigi oggi siamo dati
[Musica]
allora ghazi se questi video hanno pochi
io vi spacco la faccia scherzando non vi
spacco però la cosa volevo dirvi è che
questo gioco merita quindi dovete guarda
non mi hanno pagato per falso gioco che
non è un placement però un gioco
bellissimo guardatelo e veramente troppo
bello che non possono farlo me ne sbatto
lo farò anche se avrà una views me ne
sbatto troppo bello e mi così supermario
quelli va bene vediamo cosa ci riserva
oggi è quello che penso è quello che
pensa l'api brand è veramente quello che
pensi hanno fatto flap i third su white
dei golf ragazzi cioè io non so che dire
hanno veramente fatto flap il decesso
gioco incredibile non frati parleremo la
pipa verdi flap i birdie birdie sarebbe
una roba che cosa lo spiega la palla non
è quella sono ma questo 6 sta roba
sembra una cipolla che lo devo andare là
[Musica]
non funziona forse perché devo prendere
il cugino devo prendere così il punto
interrogativo il punto esclamativo qui
aspetta che ci arrivò a cui non ci
arrivo beta o inglobato la pallina
dovevo inglobare la pallina però aspetta
che prendo anche ponte botte schivo
attivati non si prendeva bene alla baia
fine devo portare la pallina da ping
awbab lei va bene non ha un senso
scarola prove è diventato non è questo
non è un gioco di golf è successo
no io no
devo schivare i gol di ai latin va bene
a madonna che salvataggio
io no perfetto bob li avevo fatto a
forza livello allora uno di due l'ho
fatto e manca questo hanno rifatto la
musichetta di supermario sul lato del
golf ma questa è una cover dei
pentatoniche mario ha assunto una nuova
e una forma finale sta roba ragazzino
veramente fiato mario versione del golf
mai vista
ok il summit mario non so cosa ci siamo
formati esattamente per quello non è un
ballo ragazzi andiamo avanti in poi sono
fortissimo volevo esattamente fare
questo rimasta londra del tizio va bene
arriviamo alla bandiera eccola è scesa
anche la bandierina perfetto o mio dio
donkey frog scommette scommettete che la
scritta che compare la fine e donkey
frog quanto ci scommettete senonché
fronte ne vado porca vacca molto
difficile plugin è difficilissimo ce
l'ho fatta donkey golfo senso forse
donkey frog che sfiga la ho trovato
anche indovinare c'ero quasi un ora
quello era don t proprio va bene golf
nota 1 il golf è davvero noioso forse
possiamo risolvere il problema ma mi sa
che l'avete risolto poi comunque non è
noioso il golf a me piace avete mai
provato a fare a giocare a golf davvero
impossibile colpire la pallina
impossibile va bene e siamo ancora
rimasti a supermario cosa posso fare qua
devo portare o male importa cristiano
rapa sembra una rapa quello che
personaggio che sto usando quindi
cristiano attenzione è proprio lui
gigi va impararla non ce l'ho fatta devo
portare veramente la palla importa ogni
volta è diventato fifa però molto meglio
c'è anche il piemonte calcio in questo
gioco allora vai perfetto
[Musica]
non facciamoci domande cosa sta
succedendo è un pinguino lì che non
avevo visto prima aspetta che deve
andare a parla col pinguino non sono un
pinguino e allora cosa sei aperte come
ha fatto sapere quello che avevo detto
va bene andiamo anzi mangili birdie che
sarà la frase finale visto che la
ripresa maledizione per niente
credo che sarà floppy birdies e non è
proprio i verdi sono molto di sap ho
intenzione moro eccola
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti oltre che per il
tiro anche per aver indovinato la
scritta va bene e abbiamo schiacciato
l'ultimo tasto teoricamente quindi
abbiamo fatto tutto dovremmo aver
sbloccato il boss boss tra virgolette
finale non è vero perché gioco durerà
ancora molto spero perché sono mi
ammazzo accesso garantito vamonos fammi
vedere qual è la prossima all amico mio
c'è un boss da battere ciao pallina
giochiamo come l'altra volta va bene
verso il cuore a posto cavalca perché
perfetto ed è sempre difficile ci sono
le cose che cambia ogni volta ma è
bellissimo per ora tutti in tiro ok
questa non sarà mai così io sono l'ho
preso lo stesso
oh mio dio è sicuro si muove qualcosa
non è vero l'ho preso che ci fa sapere
che curò la pallina non è quella
scommetto però vabbè
no ragazzi non ci posso credere doveva
essere l'altra parte eccola perfetto
porca vacca era l'ultimo testina aiuto
non ti piazzare perfetto hai bisogno di
cinque bandiere coronate per aprire
questa porta con le bandiere coronate
che non ho capito che questa è una che
senso ha dire con coronate cos'è che
cambia il suo livello aveva risposto li
direttamente nove ragazzi camper flag ho
capito è le altre dove sono scusami me
ne sta indicando ma non l'ho mica vista
io
fammi capire due soste bandiere coronate
non ho capi non so come si coronano le
bandiere non ho idea part ii a devo
farle in due tiri
forse ho sbagliato ok quindi per
arrivare alla corona devo fare
praticamente tutte le nove di prima però
in meno tv possibile sarai fallisci o
che quindi in due tigli devo fra sta
roba
1 arco demonio è difficilissimo coronare
una bandiera ragazzi impossibile 1 a
fango las 12 e c'è il portiere palo gol
l'ho fatto l'ho fatto fatto sitting
ovation corona l'ho presa limerà ica ok
non era una corona quella che le corone
ti fanno fare cose strane tipo liberare
i cavalli a testa in giù coi palloncini
appesi questa cosa molto kringe molto
strano allo stesso tempo però devo
liberare i cavalli e segnare in porta il
che potrebbe risultare molto difficile
soprattutto se mi calciano però
attenzione o sono più tre tiri porca
vacca
no il nostro p3 tiglio saranno ai
cavalli sono quelli non buono pallonetto
sul cavallo non vedo è l'ultimo lì
dietro ma poi ci arrivo no no non andrai
porta come piano piano davanti perché
non davanti
bravissimo bravissimo bravissimo uno ne
manca uno che quello force georges
ricava ha quindi non deve neanche centra
la porta coronato la bandiera è una ce
l'abbiamo
ora cavalca quanto incasina questa roba
è il salve mamma mia che bel naso non
dava mica visto fatto fare gol e basta
ma inutili tv che pirla non ho capito e
di meo subito cioè melavì detto subito
che non so leggere però bar buonissimo
questo buonissimo posto tre tiri due
tiri un tir o no una prova da prendere
le corone è veramente difficile non ho
capito cosa dovrei fare a parte questo
attenzione ottimo tiro alto perfetto 2 1
boh mamma mia ragazza effect stato
veramente difficile
corona fai gol con me stesso aiuto dove
la nuova per noi ragazzi non ce la posso
fare
non è impossibile è impossibile aiuto è
impossibile non riesco neanche a e
difficili come faccio cari e grandissimo
crisman attenzione portiere il portiere
esiste non un certo iter gol golf va
bene non ho preso la la questa era
facile vabbè 3 corones sul 5
andiamo per la quarta no aspetta che non
ho capito mi dicono manteniamo sempre
vendetta della pali o mio dio che senso
vendetta della pallina ajo picchio la
gente mio dio che botte così che devo
fare
a dominare la gente fino ad arrivare
alla fine non ho capito devo picchiare
ti devo far fuori tutti non potevo fare
aiuto
eccoci
però non c'è la bandiera devo far fuori
tutta la gente in realtà ok non avevo
capito di melo prima la vendetta della
pallina 21 perfetto ball wings almeno
uno di pooling ragazzi no non ci credo
ma devo azzeccare inclinazione della
palla proprio sì vabbè se non è meglio
salatino all'indietro
se come satiro tipo esatto
incredibile proprio lui non li ho
buttati giù tutti perfetto bowling
bellissimo ragazzi quindi cosa facile
dai scherzavo a quanto pare no eh vabbè
strike sciopero ok mi ricorda quello di
wii sports lo ricordate la così con una
botta facile fiori politica bellissimo
non l'ho preso mobili mi va bene a
continuare il prossimo episodio da
bowling e ragazzi bellissimo comunque
guarda del golf si conferma gioco
dell'anno come se non si fosse capito
però che vi sia cresciuta la casualità
scelto un commento mi piace iscrivetevi
al canale sky la campagna che ci è
vicino a tantissimi di molto importante
e noi come sempre ci dividiamo ad un
prossimo video è da ragazzi
[Musica]